good has never felt so good and we're
very special guest in the studio this
morning sir chris hoy and Chris well
what he hasn't done on a bike is worth
doing basically but he's here to
convince I suppose and people who are
novice to it to become more confident
and that's through what is termed sky
right now we've talked about sky ride
before it's not been going seven years
now this is not like a marathon or some
sort of big track race or something what
actually happens on a Sky Ride day well
it's been going for seven years it's an
basically tone center city center to
close down and it's a fun free event for
all the family and you just right around
when I said 10k circuit or a small
circuit for the whole day if you want
uninhibited by traffic no traffic
traffic it doesn't cost you a penny and
you know it would like snow bike do you
because I don't have a bike you follow I
could borrow bikes I'm sure you get
bikes in different locations and but
it's this for everybody it's not about
gold medal-winning cyclists and you know
high-end performance its first bucilla
you can do those Boris bikes or
something like that but here's my point
right I think all the best is very good
but how do you get to the participating
tines wherever it's Norwich Aberdeen
London whatever and it's fine when you
get there but it's getting to and from
there you can take your bait on the
train or you could cycle if you're if
you're a bit more enthusiastic but it's
you know hopefully there's enough of a
spread across the country that will be a
big bike ride near you there's also
skyraider look all which is can organize
lead raids in your area and you know
that there should be something
relatively close to the majority of the
population so these organized led led
ride sound really appealing to me cuz
I'm someone who's want see on my bike
more I'm nervous particularly in London
we hear so much about these accidents
when cars and lorries come into into
contact with with bikes I'd like to do
it more often but these guided rides
sort of help you to get confidence in
your area and show you good routes and
paths they do and they also give you
know confidence and your bite they give
you that chance to meet other people and
who are like-minded and you you can it's
a very social thing but the city centre
ones are great because you know as you
said there's no traffic motorized
traffic and you can write in confidence
you can just take your time and get you
back into cycling so it is for people
maybe who haven't ridden their bikes for
a number of years but what about you it
must bore you witless me I mean no you
are you're a speed machine you know you
want to be wined up and and set in a
direction and off you go oh you don't
want to be tootling around without the
bus I know my name and I'm retired I'm
quite enjoying the steady pace no it's
great because it's nice to be able to
enjoy riding your bike just for fun not
worrying about power outputs and speed
and performance is just riding your bike
for for the enjoyment of it and you'd be
happy to bring you a little Sun out
eventually when he's old enough
absolutely yeah i mean he's still only
brought five months old now so he's a
little bit off getting on a bike but i'm
sure when he's old enough you'll you'll
be doing at one of the sky read events
and having a go well apparently there's
a legacy associated with this because
once you do it and you take part in it
at the stats say that a lot of people
stay on their bikes well one and a half
million people have been inspired by
british cycling and Sky Ride to take up
cycling so it's clearly working I think
eight 850,000 people have participated
in sky rate events since 2009 so it's
yeah it's inspiring many people to enjoy
cycling and I think it's just it's just
showing how much cycling has grown in
the UK in the last few years while
you're here can I pick your champ cross
your grade right so and arsenal which is
my team are playing in the Champions
League tonight they've got hardly any
chance of going through they're really
up against it and as a champion who's
perhaps gone into some tricky situations
in your time what is the mentality going
into a sporting event where you have
repressed got a good chance but you got
a small one I think the worst thing you
can do is to focus on on the massive
scale of what you're about to try and
take on so i think it's about focusing
on what you have control over i mean i
know nothing about football but from a
cycling perspective i would've just
focused on the job at hand for me and
focus on the process not the actual
outcome where the potential highs or
lows of what goes right or wrong yeah
good advice Chris but it'll not matter
anyway don't worry about up there right
and my friend weren't so 15 tons in
cities taking part on this and the
cyclist take or what runs between may
and September how do you find out where
it's all going to happen I can go to go
sky right calm all the informations on
there
and there should be somewhere hopefully
poster where you live okay cool rides
course guy right here I'd calm thank you
very much didn't grant elations on being
a new daddy thank you very much stay
with us we're going to take a break
they're coming up the minimum wage is
going up but is 6.7 DNR enough the
business secretary vince cable with his
views after this you could save hundreds
on your